Henry Guen député UMP de la 3e
circonscription des iveline un élu que
l'onentend surtout dans les médias
nationaux mais hier mardi il est venu à
la rencontre de la presse locale et
aussi de ses électeurs sur la grande
scène du chînel l'occasion de demander à
celui qui se définit comme une voie
forte dans l'hémicycle comment il va
poursuivre son combat déjà bien engagé
contre le mariage pour tous la loi été
votée vous le combat doit continuer
selon vous et
comment oui mais par par tous les moyens
moi j'ai nous verrons nous verrons ce
qui va se passer maintenant s'il y a
d'autres grandes manifestations j'y
participerai et puis à chacun de à sa sa
place
de de continuer ce ce combat et de toute
façon il va se prolonger parce qu'il va
se poser la question de la PMA de la de
la gestation pour
autruie voilà la question de la théorie
du genre il il y a toute une toute une
évolution toute une une dérive à
laquelle il faut selon moi s'opposer il
y a toute
une une pente dans la sur laquelle on on
amène la société et sur laquelle moi je
ne veux pas aller est-ce que vous êtes
allé rencontrer les maires de de votre
3è circonscription pour leur dire
peut-être lancer un appel à à
désobéissance en disant ne procédez pas
à des mariages mariage gu je suis opposé
à l'idée que je seraai légitime
pour délivrer des mots d'ordre donc je
je l'ai dit depuis le début de cette
affaire un sujet comme celui-ci c'est
une affaire de conscience d'abord les
maires ont un mandat qui leur été confié
par leurs électeurs pas par leurs
députés et puis c'est une question de
conscience moi je ne suis pas descendu
manifester dans la rue parce que mon
parti avait demandé que manifester dans
la rue J suis allé parce que ma
conscience me dictait d'y aller parce
que c'était ma conviction profonde et
donc je considère que les maires sont
devant euh pour chacun d'eux devant un
problème de conscience et moi je l'ai
dit je ne jetterai la pire à personne ni
à ceux qui ont conscience se sentiront
obligés d'appliquer la la loi en mariant
eux-mêm ni à ceux qui en conscience se
refuseront à à faire eux même des des
mariages chacun le fera avec sa sa
conscience et ma position c'est c'est
vraiment celle-ci agissez en conscience
hen devrait donc jouer un rôle nationale
toujours mais on devrait aussi le voir
pendant la campagne des municipales en
mars prochain il entend soutenir les
candidats de sa circonscription investi
par l'UMP même ceux qui sont revenus
aussi dans la famille de l'UMP comme
Philippe Briot le maire du chînet ou
encore Olivier de la porte le maire de
la selle saintclou un temps exclu pour
avoir maintenu au législatif sa
candidature contre Henry Guenot
Véronique cotéiè la merère des clés
sousbois passé de l'UMP à l'UDI
récemment de Jean-Louis borlot recevra
aussi son
soutien bien sûr je vais soutenir tous
les maires de la
circonscription que nous aurons décidé
d'investir nous je veux dire dire l'UMP
puis j'irai soutenir ailleurs dans le
département et ailleurs en France que
vous soutiendrez par exemple Philippe BR
bien évidemment bien évidemment d'abord
parce que ils seront tous les deux
investis parce que le maire de
lesousbois é ma suppléante donc la more
des choses c'est quand même que j'aille
la soutenir elle a été là dans les
moments ile de cette campagne
législative et quand on regarde son son
bilan au clé sousbois il n'y a pas de
doute qu'elle mérite d'être réélu donc
j'iris la soutenir enfin dernière
question posée à Henry gu elle concerne
cette fois Pierre Bédier candidat dans
une cantonnale partial à Manent la jolie
dans le premier tour a lieu le 30 juin à
la fin du mois Pierre Bédier ancien
président du conseil général avait été
condamné en mai 2009 dans une affaire de
corruption il a purgé sa peine il est
redevenu éligible en mai dernier Henry
gu lui apporte un soutien sans faille
je le
soutiens Pierre Bédier que je connais
depuis très longtemps qui a depuis
longtemps je l'ai dit dans le communiqué
que j'ai fait paraître mon amitié ma
confiance et les épreuves de la vie n'y
ont rien changé voilà donc je suis très
content de le voir aujourd'hui candidat
je serais très content demain qu'il
occupe à nouveau une place importante
dans la politique du département c'est
simple malgré tout de de soutenir même
si c'est un ami quelqu'un qui a été
condamné d'abord j'ai ma propre conv
sur ce qu'il a fait ou ce qu'il n'a pas
fait et deuxièmement il
a accompli les peines qu'on lui avait
imposé à T raison mais qu'on lui avait
imposé voilà et donc je je je trouve
assez extravagant que on s'interroge
toujours sur le
pardon qu'on doit accorder à ceux qui
ont commis des délits extrême gravité à
tous les voyou de la
terre un
élu lui n'aurait
absolument droit à aucun
pardon à aucune
mensuétude Pierre Bédier est aujourd'hui
éligible au regard de la loi donc il se
présente et je le soutiens sans état
d'âme et en plus j'ai la conviction
profonde que c'est quelqu'un
d'honnête voilà la justice à son point
de vue et moi j'ai le mien à Noé que
nous reviendrons à la fin de cette
édition plus en détail sur ce meeting
cette réunion d'Henry guenau reportage
complet à suivre